the amy winehouse foundation works with
young people
so um through the pandemic we've had an
increase in young people reaching out
for help
i mean it's good that people are
reaching out for help obviously
but um you know these uh statistics that
we're seeing about
an increase in in use of substances be
alcohol prescription drugs or or
illegal drugs um is obviously very
concerning at a time when
there are reductions in funding for
addiction services
yeah indeed so and um mitch
of course you set up the amy winehouse
foundation um you've been doing
incredible work
over the last nine years you've seen
what's happened during lockdown that
must be so frustrating for you
and and for others that find themselves
in a similar position as you losing a
daughter
well it's not only frustrating for us i
mean obviously we lost our daughter
uh but the current situation you know
young people having to deal with
loneliness
and um the other things that have to
fail homesickness
doesn't make the situation any better
we've got to try and figure out a way
how those kids can get back home during
terms of
break time yeah jane um talk to me about
youngsters who might be watching this
morning who are
struggling who might have lost their
jobs who are not with their loved ones
who are
blocked down in universities or whatever
and are on the
on the teetering on the edge of
substance abuse
uh yeah well isolation is a big driver
for for substance misuse isolation
loneliness um
are big factors we know that um you know
and obviously
you know financial implications as you
just mentioned there okay
they're all very concerning um i mean
we'd encourage people to
especially ones that are away at
university at the moment for the first
time in in you know in different
surroundings
um for people to really stay in stay
connected with other people
you know people have to physically
distance but it doesn't feel like they
have to
yeah it doesn't mean that they have to
um distance themselves from their old
friends and their own
that that you know their family and
people like that um there are
lots of places where young people can
get support there's a myriad
of support provision if people look at
our website that's the
amywinehousefoundation.org
they can see places where they can get
help
with most colleges the pastoral care
for students is is is very good colleges
are
generally very supportive so um there is
help
out there um for people that that need
it
um you've been launching a new film i
think i'm writing saying
mitch um about the recovery from
substance
abuse disorders tell us more about that
well the film was produced in the usa
it's come over here
we are one of their partners in the uk
and
it's a very hard hitting film about
addiction and how
easy it is for young people to slip into
addiction
[Music]
the thing that resonates with me about
the film is
the empathy sorry not the empathy what's
the word i'm looking for
the the the the the most difficult
thing about the film is is the parents
complete and total lack
of um understanding that's the word i'm
looking for the understanding about what
their children are going through
and they're not taking any active part
in trying to
get any help they're not having any
conversations with the with the young
people and subsequently it's making it
work
they think that they think the whole
thing's going to disappear
um yeah you were right um talking about
lack of empathy
there mitch and jane as far as the
foundation is concerned
how do people find out more about it
um and is it aimed at
the people that are suffering
potentially from substance abuse or is
it
aimed more at those loved ones around
them or or is it both
um yeah it's i mean as we're a charity
for young people
so um we have education programs in
school
we uh work with people in recovery
um who go into schools they talk about
their experiences and the underlying
issues that made them
more um likely to
use substances to change the way that
they felt so the focus is very much on
the underlying issues
you just have a recovery house for young
women um
so you know and all of these projects
obviously going to be helped by
by the film because all of the proceeds
from the from the snow babies film
are going to be helping to fund our
services
um do you do you still listen um often
mitch
um and jane to to amy's work
well um more than we used more than we
used to
you know i mean i remember us i i i
don't know
i don't if you remember kay we spoke
many years ago and
um i couldn't bear to see amy on the on
a video or listen to her music
but you know what i'm in the last couple
of few years
i've actually begun to appreciate her
music a great deal
and um you know i mean we miss her we
miss it dearly but
nothing's going to bring her back and we
just got to move forward and
um the foundation is doing great work in
her name so i think we're making the
best under the circumstances yeah
i i remember um chatting to you
previously mitch and i remember you
saying that
that it was difficult for you to listen
to her music which is why i wanted to
check with you first do you mind
if we just share a little bit with our
audience
go ahead thank you let's have a quick
listen to amy winehouse
[Music]
i won't go
[Music]
what a talent she was both of you
listening to the words i'm sure they're
so poignant as well for you mitch
27 years of age when she died gone too
soon yeah
yeah that that that that song was a
result of a conversation
that she and i had with her managers in
our kitchen when we lived down in kent
it's literally
word for word uh what happened in the
kitchen and she turned that into a song
it's quite incredible
yeah i'm sure you miss her but what a
great talent she has
left behind and i often listen to her at
home actually i i think she's
amazing um thank you so much for taking
the time both of us to
both of you to join us this morning we
really appreciate it look after
yourselves